bonjour jean marc governatori bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france alors on
l'a vu poursuite du confinement ce
week-end à nice est toujours à dunkerque
évidemment le département des
alpes-maritimes qui reste l'un des plus
touchés les hospitalisation en
réanimation diminue légèrement
finalement le confinement partiel ce que
c'est approprié selon vous je pense que
les différents gouvernements de leurs
pays continuent leur camp cours des
compétences et c'est certainement pas
approprié de déprimer les personnes et
de les empêcher faire du sport par
exemple
bon alors là vous faites récemment c'est
à ce qu'a dit le maire estrosi qui dit
laissons une à une ou trois heures de
plus justement pour les les habitants du
département afin qu'ils puissent sortir
et prendre l'air dont vous êtes d'accord
avec avec ça il m'arrive d'être d'accord
avec monsieur estrosi
cela dit le samedi 10 blancs le dimanche
10 noir mais il n'en reste pas moins
vrai que j'ai très très grave la façon
dont est géré cette crise sanitaire dans
les alpes-maritimes et en france mais
c'est vrai qu'il avait appelé à ce
confinement le maire de nice et
aujourd'hui il dit qu'il n'est plus
d'accord alors comment est ce que vous
comprenez cela mais monsieur estrosi le
champion de la communication et donc
pour exister il dit des choses qui se
contredisent les cetc terrible pour la
vie d un million d'habitants des
alpes-maritimes qui subissent les
incompétences politique locale et
nationale
gabriella talent a dit que les mesures
fonctionner lui alors que les services
de réanimation se remplissent écouter
gabriela talent et et on en parle après
ce qui montre que notre pays résiste à
l'épidémie que les mesures de freinage
fonctionne de l'autre côté nos services
de réanimation sont de plus en plus
plein sont de plus en plus mobilisés et
les disparités territoriales sont fortes
d'un territoire à l'autre l'épidémie n'a
ni le même visage ni la même
férocité la situation hospitalière est
ainsi particulièrement préoccupante en
ile-de-france dans les hauts de france
et en région sud
il ya beaucoup de contradictions et
indique les mesures de confinement le
week-end ça fonctionne mais il ya plus
de personnes en réanimation
l'île de france est toujours pas confiné
vous trouvez que c'est juste ben sinon
en relais pourquoi l'île de france ne le
ferait pas mais il faut regarder le
factuel une écologiste si une personne
réaliste le taux d'incidence par exemple
dans les alpes-maritimes ses 500
personnes pour cent mille ça veut dire
que sur 1000 personnes prises au hasard
cinq sont testées positives ça ou pas de
la formation testée positive sur les
cinq îles ont bien été positive
il y en a au moins de 4 durant aucun
symptôme et pour ça vous aller polluer
la vie de 1 million d'habitants alors
que par ailleurs on sait très bien que
les personnes à problèmes sur les
personnes vulnérables
s'il fallait malheureusement prendre une
décision de confinement elle ne devrait
concerner que les personnes vulnérables
pouvez pas tuer le petit commerce tuer
la culture tué les espoirs des personnes
tuées le sport est en fait tu es la
santé pour des personnes quelques
personnes vulnérables c'est incroyable
de faire des fautes politiques de
décision aux adducteurs aussi grande
on va parler justement de cet impact
économique pour le département il ya eu
d'abord cette réaction du président des
alpes-maritimes écoutez je regrette
cette décision prise en dépit des
réalités territoriales et du constat que
nous pouvons d'ores et déjà dressé
l'efficacité sanitaire du confinement
partiel est encore à prouver et n'a
montré jusqu'ici qu'un effet très limité
il impacte lourdement tout un pan de
notre économie et des professionnels de
notre territoire
déjà particulièrement mise à mal depuis
près d'une année si l'on prive une
nouvelle fois les mares alpin de leur
liberté cela ne doit être qu à un prix
vacciner massivement
on va parler de la vaccination est
d'abord les conséquences économiques
pour le département quelles sont elles
c'est une catastrophe en termes de
chômage en termes de déprime je rappelle
à ceux à celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent que précarité sociale égale
précarité sanitaire et que la gestion de
la copie dit par les gouvernements
locaux et nationaux
sacré la précarité sociale donc la
précarité sanitaire et quand on voit le
niveau des primes des restaurateurs des
teneurs de ces lieux de vie des éléments
du milieu culturel
on se dit connaît là encore complètement
à côté de la plaque
mais sur le plan touristique également
j'imagine qu'il y a aussi un gros impact
abeilles c'est clair que aujourd'hui les
gens rechignent à aller ici ou là cela
dit la vraie problématique c'est
vraiment de pratiquer dans notre pays
nos politiques de santé le meilleur
vaccin c'est un système militaire qui
fonctionne le fait est que 95% des
personnes qui rencontrent le virus n'ont
pas de symptômes ou alors ont des
symptômes légers et guérissent ça
renvoie sans médicaments ni vaccin donc
la priorité ses deux enfants pratiquer
dans notre pays une politique de santé
éducation à la santé
activité physique et la qualité du bol
alimentaire ne pas fumer au réduire
l'alcool enfin des mesures simples quand
on enseigne pas aux personnes et qui
font que malheureusement certaines sont
sensibles à ce virus
comment est-ce que les niçois justement
réagissent à ces restrictions les a vus
d'ailleurs quitté littoral pour
l'arrière pays le week-end dernier ce
que ça va continuer selon vous abel
maintenant on s'organise un mec qui veut
vivre en prison en plus sans raison
suffisante
donc il est clair que les niçois
s'organise effectivement pour aller dans
leur pays pour aller dans le var ou
alors en italie voilà tout ça pour être
libre alors que l'on sait très bien
quelles sont les personnes concernées
par ce virus
et alors qu'on sait très bien qu'on peut
être en meilleure santé en quelques
semaines
il faut arrêter là la pédagogie de faire
peur il faut faire la pédagogie de la
santé mais ça malheureusement les
coureurs locaux encore bombay
vous parliez des personnes à risque on
sait que le département comporte
beaucoup de personnes âgées dans les
ehpad est ce que selon vous la situation
est satisfaisante mais c'est clair que
l'effet parce qu'une fois encore une
écologiste c'est quelqu'un de réaliste
donc les faits montrent qu'effectivement
plus la personne est âgée plus de risque
d'avoir un problème grave avec l'aco
vide mais il ya aussi des personnes
âgées qui n'ont pas qu'on l'ait
maintenant votre acolyte de voilà parce
qu'ils ont fait en sorte d'avoir une
bonne santé et par exemple vous savez
que plus
la ville est pollué plus des personnes
souffrent de conséquences graves de la
peau vide et vous savez que par exemple
en 2010 9 500 personnes sont décédées à
nice à cause de la qualité ter 500
personnes sont décédées à nice à cause
de la qualité de l'air est donc
l'élément de la pollution est un élément
souvent oubliés et qu'il faut rappeler
pour laquelle il faut prendre des
mesures admis c'est en france gros coup
de com sur les vaccins dans le pas de
calais le week-end dernier maintenant il
n'y a plus de dos pour les médecins
c'est un aveu serrures du ministre de la
santé pour le souligner regarder et donc
nous avons dit aux médecins qu'ils sont
nombreux à être volontaire et que nous
n'avons pas assez de vaccins pour leur
fournir des doses
en conséquence la semaine suivante est
donc cette semaine ils vont chercher
leur dos comme prévu il vaccine la
semaine prochaine par contre ils ne
peuvent pas commandé pour la semaine
prochaine parce que nous n'avons pas ces
doses pas pas assez de doses en c'est
assez rare que le gouvernement
l'admettent
qu'en est il à nice est ce que vous
aussi à la mairie vous faites cet appel
à une accélération de la vaccination
avec des doses supplémentaires
pour ce qui me concerne je suis pour la
liberté vaccinale mais n'ont donc les
personnes qui veulent se baptiser le
font c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas ne le
font pas donc mais qui concerne les
vaccins il faut encore rappeler les
faits et de rancoeur pour se refaire les
bassins il a une durée de protection
cyprotex une petite fille prochaine mais
s'il protège c'est sur une durée courte
après il ya la crise donne en a pris
elle provoque des allergies donc 25% des
princes et sont allergiques et donc
qu'ils sont pas en situation de faire
vacciner et donc pu véritablement il
faut se dire la vérité la seule solution
c'est une éducation à la santé
la seule solution c'est de réduire les
pollutions pour qu'on soit même de
rencontrer le virus et de l'oeuf en
subir les conséquences
il y aura dix mis un peu de temps ça
risque de prendre un peu de temps de
réduire la pollution née il ya plus tôt
urgence non avait justement madame
depuis l'on fait ça fait un an que l'on
parle cp depuis le mois de mars l'année
dernière donc depuis le mois de mars je
n'aurais pu prendre des mesures en
matière de qualité de santé en métier en
matière de pédagogie de la santé et
regardez le vaccin ça prend du temps
en théorie fallait des années pour le
faire fut là par miracle on a utilisé
une technique novatrice et que la
technique arn
donc on l'a fait plus vite mais le fait
est qu'il ya des éléments scientifiques
qui se contredisent qui disent que avec
ça au niveau élevé mais on est protégé
deux semaines ou quelques mois qu'il
faut selon les cas deux types de deux
éléments de vaccination pour être
vraiment protéger et en fait ce n'est
pas sûr quand elle donne à fond pour le
dunk à quelques rencontres et non le
fait est qu'il faut mettre le mas a
encore foutu vraiment là ce ne sont que
des solutions externes
la solution interne c'est cultiver de
bonne santé alors la bonne santé est ce
qu'elle passe par des menus sans viande
je vous pose la question parce
qu'aujourd'hui le tribunal administratif
de lyon va trancher justement cette
question qui avait fait polémique
qu'en pensez vous pour ce qui me
concerne je suis favorable à l'option
végétarienne quotidienne mais ça reste
une option dont les personnes qui
veulent manger dedans bien sûr marge de
la tempe du poisson mais je suis
favorable à l'option végétarienne
quotidienne on dit d'ailleurs loué ms
classe et la consommation de viande de
quotidienne comme serge n probable
madame donc on va on valoir
il s'agissait des cantines à lyon
évidemment la mairie de lyon qui veut
faire des budgets genre et quand
pensez-vous des budgets équilibrés donc
entre hommes et femmes
je pense que nous sommes là pour
rassembler et pas pour diviser et si
c'est vrai que le budget est qualifié de
genre et je pense que c'est un erreur de
communication
les spams via les hubs et c'est bien
chacun avec ses qualités ses défauts et
je n'aurais pas qualifié le budget de
janvier marque tout cas c'est ce
qu'affiche à la mairie de dole et lons
elle veut que son budget soit tout aussi
équilibrée pour des associations qui
concerne des activités qui sont
prioritaires pour les femmes pour les
hommes en tout cas à louer le la même
somme en tout cas pour les hommes et les
femmes est ce que vous pensez que c'est
une bonne piste
non le par exemple on a parlé de
football
eh bien il ya des femmes qui joue très
bien au football qui est lorsqu elle le
pratique adore le football donc pourquoi
le football sera utile un élément
basculèrent ehpad allemand revient donc
peu pense que sur ce point-là de
désapprouver de lyon merci beaucoup jean
marc governatori d'avoir répondu ce
matin en direct à nos questions sur arte
france